I really like love the oneechan at the
bus stop it's so posh and can you
believe Bree uploaded a bus shelter
picked the next day I've even she's so
emulous oh yeah did you hear about the
pentagram gallery contest Amy you there
oh yeah sorry what did you say
they're holding a competition on Penn
staff the winners are going on display
in a gallery in New York and the top
prize gets a high end camera you should
enter you could totally win yeah maybe I
will
oh you must be the new neighbor
that's me Amy Tucker how are you liking
it so far it's nice kind of scary living
alone though
yeah must be nice having all that extra
space so yeah I have all of these empty
closets I take it you're new to the area
mm-hmm
still adapting trying to figure out what
restaurants deliver and where the
cheapest gas stations are and such uh
you know we have a list of that sort of
stuff on our fridge from when we moved
it we don't need it anymore you can have
it if you want oh thank you
I'd appreciate what unit are you I'll
bring it by 22:37
okay I'll drop by later it was nice
meeting you
hello
yes this is our stationary but I mean
anyone can get ahold of this is it
possible that someone made a copy of the
key maintenance maybe an old tenant we
just changed the locks and maintenance
is out of here before 9 p.m.
did you actually see someone no I guess
it's probably nothing
Amy is this your first time living alone
sounds to me like your imagination has
gotten to your head classic mana phobia
I'm gonna write you a prescription for a
sleep medication just until you've a
Clemente to the movie a lot better
actually the doctor gave me some pills
to help me get to sleep in the
nightmares have subsided oh and I took
the perfect photo to submit for the
contest
that's great and while you're feeling
better I just know you're gonna win
thanks for watching live alone don't
forget to like this video and share your
scariest home alone experience it don't
forget to subscribe